hey friends and welcome back to deep
dive my name is ali and in each episode
i speak to entrepreneurs authors
creators and other inspiring people
about how they got to where they are and
the strategies and tools that can help
us along our share journey of living
healthier happier more productive lives
my guest this week is dr rupee orgler an
nhs medical doctor entrepreneur and
podcaster whose life changed when he
suffered a serious heart condition at
the age of 23 while working busy shifts
as a hospital doctor but with the power
of nutritional changes and lifestyle he
was actually able to reverse his
condition and because he was then keen
to share the medicinal effects of eating
well and living well rupee started an
instagram page called the doctor's
kitchen which soon gained a ton of
popularity and evolved into a podcast
into a website into a blog an app
multiple best-selling books multiple tv
appearances the whole shebang in the
conversation me and rupee talk about a
lot of different things including his
early days working as a doctor and how
he realized this thing around like how
food is actually the ultimate form of
medicine arguably we talk about stuff
like burnout and how to avoid it when
you're working busy shifts and also
trying to do stuff on the side we talk
about rupees transition from doctor
through to entrepreneur what it's like
being a celebrity and we spend a bunch
of time talking about food and how we
can optimize our diet and our lifestyles
for health and longevity i absolutely
love the conversation and we also did a
second half of the conversation where
rupee interviews me on his own podcast
so that'll be linked down below in the
show notes and in the video description
if you want to check out his podcast so
yeah i hope you enjoy this conversation
between me and dr rupi from the doctor's
kitchen all right rupee thank you so
much for coming on welcome to the show
my pleasure my pleasure man so i mean a
question that i found myself starting a
lot of these conversations with is like
it's like you know you're
you're a gp you're i've written a bunch
of best-selling cookbooks you've got
your face all over them you've been
interviewed on tv you're kind of like a
celebrity in the world of doctor cooking
kind of intersection how the hell do we
get here it's weird isn't it that word
celebrity that comes up some of my
parents friends came around a couple of
months ago and they were like you're a
celebrity i was like i don't i don't see
myself like that at all and it kind of
conjured the question as to
what is celebrity and what is
what's the new celebrity because i i
like look at you and i think you're
you're a celebrity oh i think of you as
more of a celebrity because you're like
on traditional media traditional media
you have books and you have your face on
books and it's weird because like
traditional media is dying a very slow
death i think anyway i don't think it's
going to be like radio i think we're
we're all going to be transitioning to
things like youtube and other paid sort
of streams as well especially now that
youtube has got a premium feature which
i i think is great and she knows the ads
and that's so good game-changing game
changer so productive
to not have to sit through that
anytime i see someone else watching
youtube i'm like why are you sitting
through ads
just pay the time go to the [ __ ]
whatever
but um yes how did we get here
yeah so by no fault of my own it was it
was never the intention to do
traditional media was never my intention
to write a book or anything it just kind
of all came at me rather than me being
intentional and manifesting it myself
you know i never wrote down i want xyz
to happen in the next three four or five
years
i literally came out this whole thing
by trying to solve a problem
that i had as a general practitioner
myself and that was based on my own
personal health story yeah but it was
really trying to get my patients
interested
in healthy eating and actually showing
them how they can cook healthy meals at
home themselves and i thought the
easiest way to scale that is to start a
social media account start a youtube
account where i put some recipes up
there and just instead of me writing
down recipes for them and scrambling at
the end of my clinic to do that i'm
you know having clinics that were
running late and later
i just thought i'd just do that and that
was really the idea behind the doctor's
kitchen and when i started
back in 2015
it was very rare for a doctor to get on
and talk about nutritional medicine and
the health benefits of food and talk
about nutrition in general because as
you know we're not really taught that at
medical school we had like two lectures
on it in first year and nothing ever
since then exactly and unfortunately
painfully it's very similar right now as
well but we're trying to change that
um and within like six months i think i
got approached by an agent i only had
about three or four thousand followers
on instagram at that point and then six
months after that i had a book deal oh
well and that's how quickly it occurred
it was it was a
very strange period of my life um and it
it happened very very fast um yeah so
i've got so many questions about that
like i i want to put a bit a bit of a a
bookmark there and let's rewind back to
for example like school and medical
school yeah what what were you like in
in school in medical school um
and sort of looking back are there any
dots that you could connect to be like
oh yeah it was inevitable that i'd
become a food celebrity
or was it complete completely out of the
blue yeah yeah so uh so school i i grew
up in east london um i was born in
barking
we moved quite early to essex and that's
where i had like most of my secondary
education ethics in uh chigwell so we
moved to redbridge and then we moved to
chicago which school did you go to i
went to bancroft no way yeah oh i've got
a friend who went there i i i told a
bmac course there no way and i went to
westcliff because we lived in essex as
well yeah
who knew
about that yeah
so we basically kind of grew up around
the same area the same area yeah yeah so
as you know it's a i mean we're how are
you 27 yeah so i'm 36. um so 10 years
apart it was it was a bit different
there weren't as many asians around uh
now i think it's it's a pretty good area
um but back then it wasn't it was fairly
sort of standard uh caucasian english
area um but i i loved it i think it was
great you know uh
school was
was a real defining point i think for
for me uh growing as a person like i i
wasn't a very confident person during
secondary school it was until the latter
years after gcse when i made the
decision to go into medicine that i grew
in confidence a bit um how did you grow
in confidence i i think it's because i
kind of got some direction as to where i
wanted to go up until the point of age
15 and 16 i was just trying to get a's
for the sake of getting a's yeah a
little help at some point further down
the line exactly and i was it was
ingrained in me from both my parents to
like you know just do well at school and
figuring out and actually my parents
never wanted me to do medicine there she
tried to dissuade me from doing it which
is very unusual for asian parents both
my parents had punjabi my dad spent most
of his his life in punjab um and uh my
mom was grew up in england as well uh in
in east london so yeah it was it was a
bit unusual for them to dissuade me but
they had doctor friends themselves and
they were like it's very hard it's long
hours you don't get paid as much
go start a business or do something in
that sort of sphere it's quite a punjabi
way of thinking from what i hear yeah
yeah very entrepreneurial yeah exactly
yeah the entrepreneurial streak for sure
so when i decided to to go into medicine
that was like i have a direction in my
life and that's that's sort of like
got me through those formative years
because i think up into that point i
didn't really have an idea of what i
wanted to do okay and i think having
some direction is really important like
that sense of purpose yeah how did you
figure out that you wanted to do
medicine so it was actually my mum who
got ill um when i was uh 11 or 12. so
she started suffering from random
attacks of anaphylaxis
which
i mean your audience who knows you know
worse form of allergy
throat closes lose your blood pressure
etc etc so when i was 11 she took me
into um the living room
and um she gave me an epi pen
and she said i need you
to take the lid off and i need you to
inject me with this epipen in my thigh
right now
and i remember taking this epipen i was
like oh my god like all right fine i did
it and i pushed it and you get that
little click and the needle goes through
and whatever um and that was a dummy
epipen so my mum was actually giving me
a task to do because she was like if
this ever happens you know what to do in
that scenario you go into mummy's bag
you grab the epipen and you inject me
only if there's no one else around and
so that sort of memory was sort of in my
in my head and around 15 16 i i went and
did some work experience with some medic
friends of ours and that that's when i
sort of connected the dots and i was
like okay that experience uh 11 12 year
got me interested
in science and medicine and you know
looking after people and that experience
within work experience age 15 16 and
that sort of gave me direction ah that's
what i want to do that's that's where
i'm heading yeah yeah
nice so you then kind of have it it
sounds like having having that direction
of like okay i'm going to go for this
medical school thing yeah you said it
kind of made me more confident yeah how
do i do that i think
having
a direction as to where you want to go
what you want to be um
definitely gave me a lot more confidence
like i could see i could crystallize
that vision of what i will look like
after i leave medicine and what
i saw when i did work experience was a
friend of us who was a gp he just had
this lovely warm rapport with all of his
patients i was sat there you know in the
corner typical sort of work experience
kid not really saying much and stuff and
he was there like hugging his patients
and they were all like big smiles and
stuff and he was a punjabi guy with a
big turban and like a real big
personality as well and that like i
wanted to be that guy at that point in
my life anyway i wanted to be that guy i
wanted to you know instill that sort of
love and connection with with people and
that's that's what gave me confidence as
to
why i was doing what i was doing why i
was you know studying medicine and you
know working long hours and trying to go
for the a's and a stars and all the rest
of it that's what gave me a lot more
confidence and then you know speaking uh
to to other medics and going through the
whole interview process
as you know they wanted you to be a
well-rounded individual they wanted you
to be this you know person that wasn't
just someone who was a bookworm but
someone who actually did you know duke
of edinburgh and all these
extracurricular activities and and that
kind of gave me a lot more confidence
something that i didn't really have
before
i think i just grew as a person as well
you know teenage years are a bit strange
and you didn't really have
as an asian kid surrounded by a lot of
kids that weren't didn't look like me i
kind of felt a bit lost you know i
didn't speak punjabi i still don't speak
hindi
i spoke english but then i wasn't like
my english friends
and then i started listening to like nit
and sony and and television sing and i
was like okay this is kind of who i am
i'm sort of lost in two generations and
i don't really have that and so that was
kind of what gave me a bit more
confidence going forward that i i felt a
bit of connection it was a i don't know
if you you're old enough to remember
like jay shawn when he came out with his
music yes it was around the same time
and i was like asians can be cool you
know yeah you know they can be like r b
singers they can do all these other
things so that was yeah that was kind of
inspiring at that time as well
interesting yeah like how how much of
the kind of desire to do medicine was
part of the asians can be cool thing do
you reckon we're going to take a very
quick break to introduce our sponsor for
this episode who is brilliant i've been
using brilliant for the last few years
and they're a fantastic interactive
platform with online courses in maths
science and computer science my personal
favorites are the computer science
courses i think are absolutely fantastic
and when i was initially applying to med
school i was actually torn between
applying to medicine and applying to
computer science and i ended up going
with medicine in the end which i really
don't regret but there's a big part of
me that really wanted to continue
learning the stuff around computer
science continuing to understand how
coding works and the courses on
brilliant have given me that foundation
in computer science which i didn't have
before the courses are really fun
engaging and interactive and the way
they teach you stuff is based on very
first principles thinking like they'll
teach you a concept and then they'll
take you through interactive exercises
to actually help solidify your
understanding of that concept and it's
pretty cool because they're always
updating the library with new courses
for example there's one they've just
released called everyday maths which is
kind of like a visual exploration of the
maths that we use in everyday life like
for example fractions and percentages
and putting them in a context that makes
it very understandable and certainly
very different to the kind of boring way
that i was taught maths when i was in
school the courses and lessons are
particularly good if you have a busy
life with lots of stuff going on because
they really teach you the stuff in
bite-sized chunks so you can always
return to a course at a later date if
you don't have time to do it in one
sitting if any of that stands up your
straight then do head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to hit that
link which is also going to be in the
video description and in the show notes
we'll get 20 of the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode i
think it was pretty genuine actually
because i didn't have that parental
pressure like you must do medicine or
you must do law or this kind of stuff uh
for me it came pretty intuitively that
that was what i wanted to do so i didn't
really get that
i yeah i didn't get that push like a
like a lot of other asian kids might
have had and so
yeah for me at least it was like this is
what i really want to do so it was quite
comfortable going into medicine okay and
then so you got into medical what was
that like over that five six year period
that was party yeah it was great i loved
it because you know even though my
parents are pretty relaxed and stuff i
don't think they were particularly you
know stereotypically strict
going and living in london i went to
imperial college lived on campus
met a whole bunch of new friends you
know
going out middle of the week and stuff
turning up late for lectures learning
all this really cool stuff getting
involved in the university that was
amazing that was great and i i look at
those years and
i just think that
those were really what made and i've got
like some of my closest friends who are
still people that i met my first year of
university and they're still like the
tightest friends that i have so that
that was a great experience and it's
sort of ingrained in everything nice and
so
like when i when when people ask about
ask me about my university years you
know i i was doing the sort of
entrepreneurial contenti thing from
fairly early on yeah um it sounds like
you had a more kind of normal university
experience like you weren't actively
weird no no i wasn't
active i would call you weird i would
say that you were like probably ahead of
the game but i don't think i had that
entrepreneurial streak uh in me from
early on i never really was like chasing
the hustle i was having deeply
meaningful conversations with my mates
at like two in the morning
i was being exposed to a different side
of culture like i never used to go out
light clubbing or anything like that
during my teens like a lot of my other
friends were doing i was at home hitting
the books and so really i had that
freedom to explore what it was like
being you know an independent individual
living in london
and that's i i really appreciate that
because i think
if i
dove straight into
you know working as hard outside of the
lectures
as i was you know
you know in in the lectures then i
probably wouldn't have enjoyed that
experience as much and i would have felt
like i would have lost out on something
personally anyway that was my that would
be my my intuition but who knows
yeah i think that's an experience that
uh
a few people i know have had who
did really well and spent a lot of time
working where they feel at the end of it
like
what was the point almost yeah like
you're still in the same foundational
hospital as everyone else and everyone
else seems to have had these like you
know genuinely interesting experiences
at university whereas if you're kind of
continuing to hit the books because
that's a game you were playing in school
yeah then
uh you know it can be unsatisfying for
some people obviously not for everyone
some people freaking love it and that's
fine people are living their best life
yeah yeah i think i was always in that
sort of like
bottom or
second to bottom quartile of medicine
throughout and like that didn't phase me
as much as
it would have other people i mean i went
to imperial and i'm sure the similar
experience with you you're dealing with
a lot of alpha type people who are just
there to win
and i didn't have that drive medicine i
knew i just wanted to be a really good
doctor and if you think about my
aspirations going into medicine it was
inspired by a general practitioner who
you know isn't that sort of
stereotypical alpha person he is a
surgeon and you're a surgeon or
someone you'd find at a tertiary
hospital uh um it's
yeah it was it was a very much relaxed
opinion i had about medicine um and and
even so midway through medicine i uh my
intercalated bsc was in management so i
i think
i must have had i really thought about
this too much but i must have had some
inklings towards entrepreneurship at
some point during my medical school
because doing management where we
learned about
marketing uh accounting um all the
different elements that make up our nhs
health system that i really appreciated
because it gave me a much
clearer understanding about the
healthcare system that we work in
and how that compares to others
that was really pivotal for me and
that's when i started thinking about
things outside medicine but i didn't
have the confidence to execute on
anything
would you mean you didn't have the
confidence uh so i didn't start a side
hustle i didn't uh start a you know
secondary company on the side i didn't
get into making my own website i you
know i didn't i might have had ideas um
but i i didn't have the confidence to to
go and chase them because i read i read
the um
we were talking about it uh four hours
but for our work week so i read the for
our working at the same time and you
know armed with that knowledge some
people go and do it straight away right
so someone like yourself you you read
that book you were inspired boom you
executed on it me i was inspired but i
was like
maybe not for me maybe i'll do this at
some point in the future excuse excuse
excuse yeah and so at that point in my
life i i didn't have the drive to to do
that yeah
do you do you regret anything about your
time in med school um
the only thing i regret is
not
not it sounds pretty fickle but like not
doing more sport
because
when you i mean i did a little bit of
sport i played hockey and stuff but i
had the opportunity to do so much more
and when you're a real adult and you've
got like a job and you've got to go in
and stuff you can't do any of that stuff
like you just can't and so the
opportunity of like having play and you
know having time to to do all these
things that that's the only regret i
really have about medicine okay um i
don't regret like starting my own side
hustle i don't regret like
not going out enough because i think i
did a lot of that stuff i had a really
nice community of people that i loved i
lived out every year you know i did an
intercalated degree that was uh aside
from the norm you know it was a very
um
diverse group of people that we had in
that management course only about 30 40
people and everyone's bouncing ideas off
each other so there isn't an element
that i really regret about medicine no
do you do you have any regrets about
medicine not really no i i mean i had a
great time i thought it was super fun
yeah um i thought my balance of work
versus other things was was pretty solid
uh the only things i regret was you know
i had a bit of a
a breakup with someone where i was i i
handled it in a way that i could i could
have done better you know things like
that where i was accidentally mean to
someone without meaning to be mean to
something and then yeah you know just
stuff and stuff like that i think like
listening to your story is interesting
because
i think when i uh the the impression i
get amongst people who watch listen to
my stuff is that
um i mean and and this is somewhat
understandable like people who have
normal jobs like someone who's working
as a junior doctor or you know their
first time job as a consultant or you
know any someone in their 20s or even
30s who has a normal job who didn't do
the hustle tech bro productivity
entrepreneur thing from the age of 12.
yeah it's like it can often seem as if
well i guess if i want to have side
hustles i i had to do it from the age of
13. i had to have done something at
university yeah and you were very much
not that person you were just like
i just want to be a gp one have a good
time i want to get to night clubs at 2
o'clock in the morning yeah yeah and i'd
be and at the time i was like i've got
to make my website screw the nightclubs
but it's cool that you had such a kind
of non-entrepreneurially
uh sort of early early days yeah um so
then you graduate medical you become a
junior doctor yeah and then you kind of
it sounded like you went through that
and became a fully fledged gp at the end
of it yeah yeah but uh a big thing that
happened to me was i i became a patient
so
three months into the job i was working
at basildon hospital um so big dgh it's
a wicked place to work you know i had
loads of friends we were living there as
well on campus but obviously as you know
stressful job night shifts really long
corridors you know running to cardiac
arrest and stuff it was yeah it was a
nightmare um and i started suffering
with atrial fibrillation episodes so
for the listeners
irregular heartbeat up to 200 beats per
minute lasting anywhere between 12 48
hours at a time
and
that was sort of um
the point at which
i realized i was a lot more vulnerable
to illness than my peers
and
i don't want to give an impression i was
a big drinker or anything like that i
wasn't smoker i didn't have a weight
issue or nothing like that i definitely
wasn't taking drugs no matter how many
times i've asked by different
cardiologists and physiologists do you
take drugs no i don't take drugs because
it's very unusual for a 24 year old to
have these episodes with no known
triggers and i would just flip into
these episodes two or three times a week
whilst i was working and i remember the
first time i had it i was admitted to
mau
and i was wheeled along the corridor
and
i had my shirt on and stuff not my shirt
i had a gown on i was hooked up to a
card monitor and all the rest of it and
that
point when i was wheeled into the ward
along that corridor i felt so
embarrassed and i had no idea what it
was like
to experience that very simple action of
just being wheeled from one ward to
another ward and i never forget that
experience of being a patient and that
was really pivotal for me
because
we can all empathize
with with patients as much as possible
um you know
with with talk communication skills and
and all this you know biopsychosocial
stuff but at the end of it if you
haven't experienced it yourself it's
very hard to to understand what that was
and so that was a really big turning
point for me and then and that's also i
guess what led me down the whole
nutrition lifestyle and health
optimization path how was that a turning
point we are going to take a little
quick break from the podcast to
introduce the sponsor of this podcast
which is curiosity stream if you haven't
heard by now curiosity streams is the
world's leading documentary streaming
subscription platform founded by john
hendricks who's the founder of the
discovery channel and on curiosity
stream they've got hundreds of really
high quality high budget documentaries
covering all sorts of things from
science and technology to history and
ancient civilizations to food and
medicine and meditation like all of this
stuff in between now the really cool
thing about curiosity stream is that
they support independent creators and so
there is this service called nebula
which you might have heard of it's an
independent streaming platform that's
run by me and a bunch of other creators
and on nebula we can put content like
videos and behind the scenes and long
form longer form stuff without worrying
about things like the youtube algorithm
and so for example in nebula i have a
bunch of exclusive content that you
won't find anywhere else we actually
have the original season zero of the
deep dive podcast which started off as
like remote zoom live streams during the
pandemic and that is only available in
nebula you won't find it anywhere else
so if you enjoy the sorts of
conversations we have on deep dive you
might like to see you know a whole year
before we started this podcast properly
once the pandemic stopped what sort of
conversations i was having with people
on zoom i've also got a series of videos
in nebula called workflow which is where
i deep dive into some of my favorite
productivity tools and on nebula you
also get early ad-free access to my
videos and videos from a bunch of other
creators that you might be familiar with
like thomas frank and tom scott and
legal eagle and lindsey ellis and the
really cool thing is that because
curiosity stream love supporting
independent creators we've got another
bundle deal which is that if you sign up
for an account on curiositystream you
actually get free access to nebula
bundled with that so if you head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive then for less than 15 a year you
can get full access to curiosity streams
incredible library of documentaries and
also free access to all of the stuff on
nebula bundled with that so head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive to get the bundle deal so thank you
curiosity stream for sponsoring this
episode so i went and saw a number of
different cardiologists um some of whom
are
best in europe if not the world i had
electrophysiology studies i had all the
investigations you can imagine i was
going to have an ablation which is a
relatively simple procedure it was sold
to me as curative although now we know
it's not as effective as as we'd like it
to be um but it's where you you burn an
air around the pulmonary vein to stop
misfiring cells i had all the studies to
demonstrate that it was af not something
else like a re-entry pathway or a
different type of
svt
and um
i was gonna have this ablation i was uh
i was gonna have uh warfarin for a
couple of months to pre-empt and stuff
and
thin the blood exactly yeah yeah um
there were some other procedures i think
at the time like cryo version which
doesn't require warfarinization but
anyways gonna have warfarin and i
remember my girlfriend at the time uh
dragged me down because i was dragging
my feet with this whole thing and she
dragged me down to the uh
the the anticoag clinic i was like
you're going to start warfarin right
today and anyway long story short my mum
was the person that said to me you
really should optimize your diet and
lifestyle give it six months if you've
got time
before you entertain doing something
quite drastic like an ablation and in
her mind you know someone's going into
her son's heart and burning a hole in it
that was literally how she described it
yeah which you know it's
technically it's what
happened kind of what happened as
drastic as that yeah um so so anyway to
appease her i thought okay
i'll do this diet and lifestyle stuff
you know i'll speak to my cardio
cardiologist first
and make sure you know i'm not putting
myself at risk but ultimately i'm going
to have this ablation like this it's
what she's saying is so stupid um
and so i was on fleck and eyed as and
when which is an anti-arrhythmic drug i
was on bresoprolol uh antihypertensive
medication as well um and
what happened over that six month to 12
month period is i just started
optimizing very small things at a time
so out went serious in the morning uh
and then i in came like leftovers from
the night before
were you like at the time or what no i
wasn't fat or anything i've always been
fairly lean okay but i was eating a lot
of refined
sugars and carbohydrates it was you
can't when look when someone looks at my
diet
back then they'll just say it's a normal
diet for a junior doctor it's cereal
with maybe a little bit of juice
uh if i'm feeling healthy maybe some
frozen berries on top and
uh it would be like a soggy sandwich
from the hospital canteen or whatever
slot they were serving uh it would be
something probably taken at like seven
or eight pm on the way back from work
because you know we don't have any time
to cook
um it just was a normal way of eating it
was pretty normal pretty accurate for a
lot of people and i don't want to
demonize like what is normal for a lot
of other people but certainly for me
combined with the added stress of poor
sleep with the added stress of learning
new things from the job for the first
time the added pressure you know all
that all that kind of stuff
that
compounded and resulted in me having a
heart issue that's the only way i can
really conceptualize as to why this was
happening because when i optimized all
those different things it went away and
i appreciate there's lots of other that
just like went away yeah yeah after well
not immediately after about a year of
optimizing things slowly but slowly so
what i would be fastidious at would be
tracking when i was having these af
episodes and so you know be a tuesday at
work 3 p.m lasted x number of hours and
then the next day would be like oh
friday came in last about four hours and
i'd also look at triggers before what
was i doing that that morning had i had
i worked out had i gone for a run had i
had any coffee i didn't drink coffee at
the time um you know what things had i
eaten before you know what kind of stay
what was my sleep like all those
different things i was looking at it
pretty you know
vaguely uh to just get some
accountability as to what might be going
on and so
after looking at all these different
things and changing a few things in my
diet bit by bit outward cereals out when
like sandwiches at lunch time in came
like me bringing tupperware i was
labeled tupperware boy by my consultant
at the time of respiratory medicine it
was you'd always you know take the piss
at me which is great you know it was all
like all banter yeah um and then yeah
just all those different elements and
then i started getting into like
stress reduction meditation i'd been
taught how to meditate by my parents
when i was a teenager and so that kind
of came into play again and then when i
wasn't doing night shifts i was you know
trying to tuck myself into bed a little
bit earlier and instead of just doing
like running i was a keen runner at the
time i would do things like yoga and
mobility and flow and all these things
that sound a bit woo-woo but i thought
of sort of just started getting into it
from the very little research that i did
at the time and yeah after a year and a
half i noticed like af episode went from
one a week then one every two weeks and
then one a month and then i remember
vividly i was like it's been three
months i haven't had i haven't had an
episode i went to see my cardiologist
i was seeing two at the time and they
said look
sometimes af can go through a period of
like where it just goes away and it will
come back but
it's likely to come back so just be
aware of that and then i went to a year
and then a couple of years and then you
know it's been over 10 years now and i
still i still see my cardiologist i
still have like checkups and all the
rest of it but i went away and so that
that was
my introduction
into
a how on earth is this possible like
what why would that make a difference
and b
why weren't we taught this kind of stuff
if it is effective
even though it's anecdotal yeah
we should really be looking further at
this and actually when i did a bit of
research i realized like you know
there's things that we can do for things
like type 2 diabetes the things that i'm
seeing every day obesity obviously is
the most obvious one cardiovascular
disease dementia and then you know the
more research you do the the bigger you
realize that there's this
huge amount of literature that we've
just been sitting on we haven't really
been put into practice and so that was
that was how i got into it i guess oh
wow yeah that sounds that sounds pretty
magical where you literally just sort of
track
your uh af episodes and be like oh it
turns out that when i actually get good
sleep and when i meditate to get less
stressed i have fear of these episodes
what the hell yeah because i guess to my
mind it's like oh yeah sleep health
yeah this kind of stuff it's all kind of
a long term type thing yeah i'll sort it
out at some point but you we don't
really and we were talking about this in
the previous the previous interview as
well we don't really think inter
like that long term about stuff yeah so
i guess for you you had that very clear
feedback loop of like oh [ __ ] this this
stuff actually works yeah this is the
thing we were talking about because a
lot of the things that i talk about
within the diet and lifestyle space
people thinking oh that's to prevent me
getting you know fat and overweight and
type 2 diabetes when i'm 45 50 55
you know you don't really have that
immediate feedback as to i need to start
doing this now to optimize my health to
improve my longevity and also to perform
my performance right now
we don't really have that sort of
connection and because i had that
immediate feedback with my own condition
and my threshold for illness is a lot
lower than other people of
the same age group
that's kind of what propelled me uh
forward yeah so i guess
yeah i'm trying to think of what the
equivalent would be it's like if if for
example
i could wear an arrow ring or something
that would tell me your performance
today was 85 yeah and i'd be like oh it
turns out that when i don't eat kfc my
performance goes to 90 yeah that would
be great it's just we don't really have
a metric like that yeah unless you have
a health condition where you've
literally got a metric you can track
exactly and what i was doing i guess uh
back in 2009 now was pretty analog it
was just me writing down things on my
phone or notepad
um
what was happening and when it was
happening and what things i'd done
before and that was it whereas now you
know we're moving to a space where
it doesn't have to be as analog as that
and everything can be automated so you
notice i'm wearing orange i've actually
worn one for about three years
i know for example that if i eat too
late i go to sleep straight after eating
it disrupts my deep sleep and i have
much lower deep sleep than i have rem
sleep and that will impact how i perform
the next day interesting so i used to
wear an arrowing for about six months i
found i would never act on the data
because i would look at the number in
the morning be like readiness level 73
i mean okay
64. be like yeah well i know i only got
three hours of sleep last night so
obviously that's obvious yeah but i
didn't quite
if you the only things i've kind of
anecdotally noticed are when i drink
caffeine like if i find myself unable to
sleep i think did i have a coffee like
at 5 pm oh crap yeah i did did i have a
diet coke at like 10 p.m yes i did okay
cool maybe that's the problem yeah i
stopped doing that yeah um but beyond
that i didn't i don't really have all
the data points where i can track that
that number yeah yeah yeah so it's
interesting what you said about caffeine
because i've just done a 30-day caffeine
free sort of fast and i love coffee i
absolutely love coffee you know i love
the ritual the roma everything um so i i
take coffee out of my diet for uh
probably once a year for 30 days and i
was tracking i was looking quite
carefully at my aurora ring this time
around and my deepen rem sleep was so
much more improved and i usually only
drink caffeine before 12 pm as well i'm
not one of these people that has at 3 pm
so i'm pretty sensitive to caffeine as
i've realized and so
now that i've gone back to drinking
regular coffee again i'm going to be
having it even earlier and i know
anecdotally over the last 10 days since
i've started that again my sleep's a lot
better so the the thing is i i'm of that
i'm of that way of like trying to
optimize everything exactly and tracking
those different things and that that
appeals to me but it might not appeal to
a lot of other people listening or
watching to this it depends on like what
their intrinsic drivers are yeah i mean
it definitely appeals to me i actually
was uh recently ordered the latest arrow
ring and i just haven't
haven't sent them my sizing it's just
been i've just been on the bedside table
for the last like do it i bought the new
one as well it's really good it looks
like the fancy one yeah the issue so i
went i went for the kind of like that
black color as well but anytime my mom
sees
me with it she like basically has a
stroke she's like oh my god why are you
wearing jewelry it's really bad oh
really
as you can tell like i don't wear
anything i don't wear watcher that wear
a necklace or anything this is the only
i've joked with my fiance that um what
she needs to do instead of getting me a
ring is just getting me an aura ring for
my uh ring finger oh yeah that'll be
good yeah she's not on board with that
she's not bored of that that's a shame
so we were talking about arrow rank
tracking tracking stuff having those
metrics and then being able to sort of
optimize your lifestyle based on that
um i want to ask you a lot more about
those specific things but let's if we go
kind of back to the story then so you
had you realize the impact that these
different
health and like yoga meditation type
changes were genuinely having on your
life as evidenced by the fact that your
atrial fibrillation episodes were
reducing in frequency um
so at that point most people would be
like all right cool it's a thing i've
sorted my diet out yeah what happened
next time what happened next yeah so
i started having more open honest
conversations with patients about it um
so i started gp training i moved down to
brighton one of the best things i ever
did i was actually that was a mini
failure actually so i was actually
trying to stay in london because my
girlfriend at the time was living in
london
and when i didn't get into
london i i almost considered taking a
full year out actually and just doing
something different i'm really glad i
didn't but went to brighton started gp
training and i got
known i got a bit of a reputation as
being that gp who would talk to the
patients about nutrition
and and then like
my clinic started getting longer and
longer and as a trainee you get like 20
the third 25 minutes and so i'd use the
whole 25 minutes and then like it would
go over and then i started writing down
recipes um i realized i didn't answer
your question earlier about
how i got into food and
my whole family are all foodies right so
we'd always have the food channel on on
the tv when we're growing up and stuff
watched saturday kitchen for years like
i love saturday kitchen is like my
favorite show
for the for the american audience
especially a cooking show and it's
really popular actually i think dave
grohl's going to be on this saturday as
well like it's just one of those iconic
bbc shows yeah um
so we'd always had that and like when i
was at med school i lived in a house
which which was really experimental with
food and it wasn't necessarily healthy
food it was like you know barbecue or
pastas or steak sandwiches and herb
blends and all that kind of stuff so
i've always been into food from that you
already had that kind of background in
food stuff yeah like while i was doing
coding you were doing cooking yeah nice
so the same thing yeah
so yeah though
i would always have that ability to
reflect what someone wanted to eat
with little tweaks and hacks that could
make it slightly healthier for them so i
remember uh chatting to a guy about um
his his breakfast routine and he had you
know he was on the verge of type 2
diabetes it was classed as metabolic
syndrome and so we i started talking to
him about oats and like you know
changing up his oats and adding a few
spices and pumpkin seeds and while those
might be healthy and he like his eyes
lit up i remember that moment because i
started having more conversations with
people from different backgrounds
jamaican background korean background
sri lankan background all these
different elements and they would tell
me about their food that they would eat
like sri lankan guy i remember i learned
about cashew curry for the first time
from from this guy who had ibd and i was
like okay well maybe we could tweak this
and add some green peas or like what
kind of green vegetables do you like or
how do we get more fiber in your diet
all the different stuff and again like
people just lie up it wasn't me just
saying you need to eat better you need
to get saturated fat out of your diet
you need to make sure i have too much
sugar here is a healthy plate with a
kale salad on it it wasn't that it was
like making it
super interesting and something they
felt that they really wanted to try out
themselves and give me and empowering
them to do it and that's sort of where i
found my purpose um
and
that's where i got the idea for the
doctor's kitchen it was really early it
was like back in
2012 i think um but i didn't i didn't do
anything
about it so at this point you're you're
a gp trainer you're having a 25-minute
consultations which is like two and a
half times longer than a normal gp would
have because they have 10 minutes and
you're like you're finding yourself
giving people lifestyle advice but
instead of just doing the thing that i
would do in that case which is but be
like hey you know you should probably
eat a bit healthier
like how like i don't know
i'll let you know when i find out you
know maybe order a pokeball from
delivery rather than just a you know a
fried chicken you are actually like
writing down recipes based on your
previous sort of uh sort of tacit
knowledge of the cooking world from like
a decade of consuming saturday night uh
saturday morning kitchen
i think it was yeah yeah yeah that's
really cool yeah yeah it was it was like
i i mean i've got like a huge collection
of cookbooks i've learned from obviously
the the greats like jamie oliver nigella
and nigel slater these guys like
understand flavor super well um and i
was able to apply that knowledge to what
i was doing in clinic was it was a bit
of a surreal feeling actually
and i mean i guess now with with
hindsight you can say that i was molding
my passion with with work and i was
turning my work into you know something
that i found quite playful rather than
just going through the
the algorithms and choosing okay this is
the medication you need and you know
being a sort of robot that was kind of
where i found a lot of like the the
colorful elements of medicine that was
about so you're doing the referral to
dermatology but at the same time you're
like have you considered all the
nutrition things you could do for your
skin yeah absolutely and they're like no
i haven't really but if you tell me then
i'll figure it out yeah absolutely and
like you know it was never as like a
sold as a panacea uh it was never really
like oh you well i could give you the
stroke but really should be improving
your diet it was always like no it's a
and not a like either yeah and i think
that's really important whenever i speak
to people even on a public scale now
about food because there is this sort of
pervasive myth that it's like oh okay
well you're either on the woo side where
you're giving people nutraceuticals and
green powders and all the rest of it yes
and trying to cure cancer with like some
erroneous herbs
or you know you're you're just doing
pharmaceuticals and stuff and actually i
think we need to take that real blended
approach to nutritional medicine which
is now garnering a lot of sort of
mainstream uh interest can we do a
collab video on my channel where you
teach me some weeknight recipes yeah man
that i like healthy and productive so
that okay because because my problem
right now is like i go home and i'm like
the paradox of choice i could go to
tesco waitrose on the way home and then
i have to figure out what the hell am i
going to buy yeah what are the where's
broccoli beans carrot sprouts yeah all
the vegetables like what am i going to
use with my carbs you just get some oven
chips oh should i get roast potatoes
your fillings rice i don't know and then
it's like the protein should i go for
salmon should i get some kind of meat
should get some kind of chicken like
what's the deal with that and it's just
like you know what screw this i value my
time at x amounts per x dollars per hour
it's quicker and cheaper and easier to
get a deliveroo therefore let me just do
that and i'll spend that time i don't
know
in theory working on my book but in in
fact actually just watching youtube
videos yeah yeah and i ended up just in
the takeaway cycle because like well
yeah it's just too hard to and
i just i
don't have a system for it i don't have
a process and i think i'm quite a sort
of default kind of guy that if i could
just have the same recipe and just re
have that on repeat every other day yeah
my life would be a lot better where i
would know exactly what i need to have
in my pantry exactly what to buy in the
supermarket yeah but i just don't right
now and so it's just delivery is the
little path of least resistance yeah no
i get you and you
you're not
you're not unique in that conundrum as
well i think a lot of people fall into
that pattern of having not having a
default and not having um a backup plan
actually one of the things i always talk
about my talks is making sure you have a
backup meal because it happens to
everyone like when i'm uh coming back
from a late shift like 8 p.m yeah uh i
i'm there like scrolling through
deliverer as well and i'm thinking you
know maybe i should just get one of
these things and to be fair to some of
the delivery companies they do have
healthy options not that we go for them
at that time
in the evening but um i always say
you're going to have a backup meal
you're going to have like a meal you can
make in 10 minutes
which you use to store a cup of
ingredients you don't have to go to a
supermarket to go get it frozen items a
few spices herbs pastes and some
nutritious ingredients that you actually
enjoy as well not something that you're
forcing yourself down for me it's this
like whole grain pesto pasta which i
have with peas and like a whole bunch of
other like herbs and spices and i can
make it in 10 minutes with my eyes
closed it's so easy and i know that i've
always got that as a backup when i'm
feeling peckish and that kind of stuff
um but yes for to collab video i'd love
to do something that because i think
instilling principles of healthy eating
rather than specific recipes i know that
we're saying this in front of my
cookbooks and stuff but like i think
that's the way to get people out the
conundrum yeah the other thing i would
say is
uh i i'm not puritanical about this kind
of stuff i don't think that we
need to necessarily in this lifestyle
that we will have to be able to cook
every single meal from scratch every day
i think there are lots of other
healthier options and i think in the if
i if i forecast in the future what i
think is going to happen
is we cook for pleasure and hopefully i
can demonstrate to people that cooking
is like a you know meditative thing and
something that you can actually enjoy
and it's pleasurable you share with
friends and all the rest of it but also
in a world where we're trying to
optimize every element of our lifestyle
we will have uh
greenhouses that surround every city in
the world which demon uh growing
optimized ingredients which are you know
phytochemical rich as well as nutrient
rich and then that will be delivered to
a ghost kitchen which is cooked probably
using robots and then that's delivered
to us using automated delivery systems
and that's probably one of the ways in
which we're going to dig ourselves out
of the hole where we have a very
unhealthy environment today that's what
i think is going to be the future and i
don't want to fight against that yeah
because i think i i'd be a bit of a
ludder if i was trying to preach to
everyone you need to cook from home
every single day and and you know it's
just against the pace of change but i i
do think
the art of cooking the love of cooking
should should not really be lost in the
same way you know we're surrounded by
books right now even though we have
kindles there is something about it
there's something intuitive
something that is hard-coded in our
evolution to love the art of cooking uh
and i i don't think we should really
lose that so hopefully i can do that for
you that'll be so fun like it's only
recently that i've i've realized that
cooking is actually fun and weirdly the
mental model that i that made me realize
this was
i was playing horizon zero dawn on the
playstation yeah and i was like you know
to get some of the equipment to upgrade
your satchels you have to go out and
like kill rabbits and stuff like in the
wildlife it's like you know this robot
apocalyptic type game but you have to
kill the occasional rabbit to get the
boar skin or whatever yeah and i was
like huh this reminds me of back in the
day when i was playing world of warcraft
where you would you would level up your
cooking skill and you'd build like a
campfire and you would turn your boar
meat into this cool thing i was like
that that was kind of fun it kind of
felt good to be cooking this virtual
virtual meet and virtual veg in a game
and i was like wait a minute
i could do this in real life what the
hell like absolutely game changing that
was like a mind-blowing moment for me
that i had a few months ago when i had
covert and i was playing horizon theory
like ten days straight yeah i didn't
normally play playstation um and then i
was like all right you know what new
year's resolution let's take this
cooking thing seriously so then i went
out and bought i actually have him over
here you know uh la crusade does this
harry potter signature edition no way so
i got no two dutch ovens and a cast iron
pan and like a bunch of spatulas and
stuff and then i got super excited about
cooking because now i had the gear which
i'd spent like a stupid amount of money
on because it had harry potter on it i
i'm gonna show you how to make the most
use of those pans for sure because those
are similar paths to the ones that
they're not harry potter
branded but those are the the same pens
that i have and i i make so much use out
of you i feel like you're about to
embark on like your own four-hour body
uh book with like tim ferriss like you
know how he like i've read that book as
well i think it was the four-hour body
of the four-hour cook something like
that
for our chef that's it yeah i've read
that book it is incredible like the
detail this guy goes into is amazing and
i feel like you're at the start of this
journey like people are probably going
to be watching live so how does this guy
not know who youtube longie is but i
reckon you know give it like a year's
time yeah
yeah it's yeah i'm excited for you man
nice yeah this is going to be fun um so
many questions on the cooking front um i
do also have it in my bucket list that i
want to do like a fishing weekend trip
where we actually fish and cook and
stuff we love that we should do that as
a collab we can vlog it as well we can
bring friends along
if there's someone who does fishing
yeah that would be that'd be so if
anyone's listening to this who
hosts fishing trips and stuff in the uk
then uh drop us an email yeah and we
would be very very interested so loads
of questions about the food thing which
i'll put a little bookmark in let's go
back to your gp you're doing the recipes
and then you go to australia after
you've done your gp training i like
leave so i quali i passed all my gp
exams really early because i was super
keen
and then the gp surgery i was working at
um lovely but they were like oh we've
pretty much got a salary gp now because
he's done with the exam so let's put him
on 10-minute consults and so i was
basically working full-time as a gp yeah
pretty much four and a half five days a
week um
quite hard yeah seeing like a lot of
people i don't think have an
appreciation for
gps and even within medicine i think i
think people who know know how how
difficult is being a gp like one minute
you're doing with like a child's ear
infection next minute you're dealing
with someone with depression next minute
you're breaking bad news about cancer
diagnosis next minute you know you're
doing something you know it's just
you're flipping gears all morning and
all afternoon and you're seeing anywhere
between 20 patients in the morning plus
the prescriptions plus the phone calls
plus the home visits and i was working
in a rural area
where um
in rural britain they just don't like uh
numbers on houses they just have like
names like the farm and it's on like a
two kilometer stretch of road and you're
just driving up and down to find this
lovely little old lady that needs her
warfarin checked and all the rest of it
so it was a very stressful time in my
life and i really burnt out
at the end of that and so i just thought
to myself i need to just get out and i
had a few friends of mine that were
living and working in australia and they
were just raved about it and i just i
called up and i was like i want to do an
any job i love a e i don't want to do
clinic at this point
and i just went out there and i
absolutely loved it it was
really game changing for me and my
clinical career but also it gave me the
space to think a bit more about the
doctor's kitchen idea that i had years
ago and that's ultimately where i i
launched it as as well when i was in
australia okay um if we just just
say we wanted to pick up on something
you say so you said that the working
working this sort of gp lifestyle meant
that you got quite burnt out yeah um
what's that like being burnt out
it is
it's where
you go
home at like 7 7 30 p.m and
you know you've got friends who you
haven't seen for a while and you just
can't be bothered and you're not excited
about seeing them even though you really
should be because you know it's been
weeks or whatever
it's where you don't you lose the
empathy
that is so required in in medicine as
well
um and i felt
that slipping away and that that wasn't
a good position to be in you know
sort of like what we're talking before
when
you've got to do something for a patient
and instead of you
having the mindset of this is a
privilege to work for people in the most
vulnerable state it's like
i've got to do this and this is my job
and i have to do this and there's
another thing to take off the list and
that's never really the way i really
wanted to feel within medicine
obviously you can't be happy joy joy the
whole time in medicine you're obviously
gonna have good and bad days and that's
just normal but when it becomes
persistent and insidious throughout your
whole week that was kind of like i need
to i need to take a break from this and
i had the sort of foresight
and the privilege and opportunity to
even do that you know a lot of people
don't have the opportunity and a lot of
my friends for example
were supporting families and they had
mortgages and they had all these other
you know um
pressures on them financially i was
independent and i had the opportunity to
go away and i was like i owe it to
myself and it to my friends who can't do
this to go out and that's that's sort of
what was the push for me to go abroad
but yeah the burnout was not nice place
and i'm i'm thankful i don't think i've
already had that
since
in some ways like obviously during the
pandemic and stuff but i think because
there was that sort of like collective
energy from everyone being in the same
bucket that kind of like pushed you
through i think it's pandering out now
which is why you're seeing loads of
people leave in droves um but yeah that
was yeah it wasn't a nice position to be
in have you ever been in that i don't
think so no that's why like because
because people do talk about burnout as
like being a thing and i'm always kind
of curious like what does that feel like
yeah because
i kind of said to a friend of mine one
point like i don't think i've ever been
burnt out she was like uh you probably
have but you just don't realize it i was
like okay fine let me yeah what does it
mean to be burnt out yeah um i don't i
don't think i have do you have the
ability to
compartmentalize
yes yeah yeah because there's a really
good podcast called how to take over the
world okay um you should definitely
check it out so they they they examine
uh different leaders across time and
history it's usually people who have
passed away
um but you'll find more recent leaders
like you know steve jobs i think they
did putin as one as one and um one of
the recurrent themes um that i've
noticed and actually the the host
notices as well
is the ability to complementalize
different issues so napoleon was able to
put things in one drawer shut it and
then open another one without really
thinking about the last draw that he's
he's closed
i'm learning that skill now but i
definitely didn't have that
when i was working as a gp and i think
perhaps that's maybe the reason why you
haven't experienced it um
but certainly you know my my in my
inability
to focus on one thing at a time is
probably why i i got burnt out and it
kind of spilled out into my personal
life right yeah built into your personal
life meaning so uh
relationships not really working out um
not being there for my friends
not having the energy to do stuff at the
doctor's kitchen for example putting
things off not being there for my family
all those different pressures i think
that's kind of like yeah how it played
out for me yeah do you think that was
inevitable given the schedule you were
on or do you think there's stuff that
you could have done at the time to kind
of mitigate those kind of personal
spillover effects oh yeah definitely i
think certainly now given what i do
with all the different strands to the
business and how i haven't really
outsourced much you know running the
podcast writing the books doing the
recipes starting the app running the
tech team doing the customer service
doing the charity stuff all that kind of
stuff i've i'm able to flick i'm still
learning this as a skill but i'm able to
flick from different roles and positions
relatively easier
easily compared to how it was before and
also having a partner who's pretty
regimented about look it's 6 30 p.m
you can't be on your computer that late
at night and you haven't spoken to me
for eight hours that kind of keeps me on
the straight and narrow as well so i'm
actually very thankful that i've got
someone who can understand the grind and
the you know the the sort of need to be
there and hustle but also
you know is when i need a bit of
rigidity to like be like you you need to
stop this and i need to pull you away so
at this point we're in australia you're
working in um the emergency department
yeah and you're sort of mulling over
this idea of doctor's kitchen like what
what is the idea in your mind in like
the early days the early days was uh
literally to be
that
gp who was inspiring people to eat well
and giving a bit of the evidence base
behind it so using research fun
delicious recipes to get people changing
their behavior such that it looks after
their health long term and so is that
always that combination of flavor and
function that i always want to instill
in any video i did and any recipe and
all that kind of stuff and
so when i started i had in my mind all
those patients that i was seeing back in
general practice and even the ones that
i was seeing in a e as well because a
lot of people don't realize people think
of any as just like we see broken bones
and
heart attacks and the rest of it and
once that does happen
you have a lot of time with patients who
are coming in with
with niggles and pains and lacerations
or you know the the product of chronic
conditions that are lifelong um and
you know i'd be chatting to them about
this kind of stuff as well
and it was i had the idea of like you
know starting the instagram i had a
wix.com website as well that i never
published and like a whole bunch of
youtube videos that i i had up there
like ready to just press play um
and it wasn't until i spoke to one of my
senior consultants about it and i was
like look i think i'm gonna do this
nutrition thing they were really forward
thinking and i really respected her
um
and she was like you just gotta do that
sounds like an awesome idea you just
gotta do it and so yeah that was the
that was the push for me to hit play and
all that kind of stuff so did you start
filming these videos when you were in
australia yeah i did and where did the
name doctor's kitchen come from it just
came out of nowhere and the intention
was never to build like a brand around
it it was just doctor's kitchen i just
had this idea yeah it'll be a website
instagram page youtube channel was that
what you were thinking at the time like
2015-16 yeah that was it was just a
website instagram i didn't know how to
use hashtags i remember i posted my
first picture and i posted it to my
personal facebook profile as well
and immediately uh i i kicked play uh
click play on it and then i i was taking
a flight to japan for six days sydney to
japan is very very close
eight hours um and it's because i was
running away from the reaction of my
friends i thought everyone's gonna think
i'm so stupid like you know this is it
was like a real cringe-worthy moment for
me
uh back then i was so scared about what
the reaction was gonna be um so i
actually uh clicked play and then i
jumped on a plane to japan and then i
got all these messages from people and
like that's amazing that's so cool and
like why are we scared i was just scared
at the time dude like you know
a gp talking about food as medicine
back then
when the wellness industry wasn't as
established as in as now like seven
years later it's it it would have been
seen i at least i thought it would have
been interpreted as a bit cavalier oh
yeah well like you want a qualified
nutritionist therefore how do you talk
about food kind of like that kind of
vibe but also like just generally like
uh getting in front of a camera and
being a doctor on youtube and instagram
and being that kind of person
sometimes it does feel like that yeah i
don't know if this was your experience
when you first got on because i i
remember hearing that
i think you did like 80 odd videos
before the the one that really kicked
everything off but
yeah
yeah i always i i was never really into
social media at the time i wasn't like
you know someone who followed joe wicks
and all these other people i found out
about them after i joined myself i i
hadn't really done much research in that
perspective i just knew what i wanted to
talk about so it came came from a place
of like just
genuinely wanting to put out good
content out there were you worried about
what your doctor friends would think
absolutely that you're peddling that oh
i'm the doctor and you're like oh i'm
just a recently qualified gp and like
what the hell do i know about anything
absolutely that was definitely and it's
still to this day if i'm being honest
there is a shred of that whenever i talk
about what i do and you know despite
completing a master's in nutritional
medicine doing all this analysis having
researchers on my team and all that kind
of stuff like i still get all that kind
of i still get that like little voice in
my head saying you don't really know
what you're talking about because i
guess the maybe you've experienced this
as well by doing so much research in
your various domains
the more you learn the more you realize
how little you know
and that you know for someone who
doesn't really want to be you know
misleading people or anything
the the the scary thing is like you know
what if people find out how much i how
little i know like always that in the
the back of my mind i'm not a researcher
that spends like day in day out in a lab
reading papers all day long like i've
got a whole bunch of other things to do
and you'll never have i'll never have i
have to
i've got you know better at um
working through this myself
i'm never gonna know enough to
completely get rid of my imposter
syndrome i just have to sit well with
how i am right now and do the things
that i know are helping people as much
as possible and just just be happy with
that
because otherwise it's you know
you just stop making content yeah yeah
this is the thing i hear from like once
once my channel started to go well while
i was still working um people would be
like oh you know like i had a friend who
was an obstetrics registrar and you know
he and his his wife had recently gone
through the whole process and he was
like you know there's a lot of
misinformation out there you know
it would be cool to do a book as an
obstetrics registrar about what it was
like being sort of going through the
process of the patient educating young
mothers about you know young mothers to
be about what the process is going to be
like
he was like oh but i can't do it now i
need to i need to wait until i'm a
consultant because then i'll be
qualified i hear that i was like when
you're a consultant are you really gonna
are you really gonna think that or are
you gonna think oh i'm a new consultant
i need to wait until i've got a diploma
in reproductive medicine and i've been
uh bringing professor for 20 years
before i think that yeah and even in
that position you're probably going to
think i'm not the world's most qualified
person to talk about this therefore i
can't talk about it yeah and i think in
medicine there is a lot of credentialism
credentialization that goes on where
it's like we we feel this internally we
feel our friends are going to judge us
for it maybe some of them do judge us
for it be like how dare you talk about
nutrition without a phd in nutritional
medicine masters anyone get a master's
through that it's just a one-year thing
phd is where it's really yeah like we
have this thing where we need another
badge another another certificate to be
allowed to do a thing absolutely and i
just try and try my best to be like look
you don't need any qualifications you're
you're being a guide you're not being a
guru yeah it's all good yeah absolutely
and you like what you've just described
there has happened to so many of my
colleagues who haven't got to that
consultancy status and then when they
get to that consult and say i've spoken
to so many different consultants who
some of whom have have actually been on
the podcast
and asked for you know the you know oh i
i did i didn't really i don't i didn't
think i said this right or i feel like
i'm too young a consultant to say these
things so i'd rather not do it like
that's fine that's you know i'm not
going to push anything but
it's a story i hear very often and it's
not just with the medicine so i'm
actually going to call someone out here
one of my good friends um a guy called
jay
who is a serial entrepreneur
he's raised millions of pounds he has a
number of different tech companies under
his belt
and he really wants to put out content
about conscious entrepreneurship right
he's super qualified to talk about it
he's been in the game for well over a
decade
and he just can't get over the edge he
just can't start with his first piece of
content to start the wheels in motion
because there's something holding him
back i'm not qualified enough i've only
been in the game for a couple of years i
haven't raised as much money as this
person so i think that sort of
credentialism
credential listening i'm saying that
wrong but um the word that we just made
up um that i think holds a lot of people
back beyond medicine as well you know i
remember when i was first starting my
youtuber course which you know we
started uh sort of october 2020
and you know it has now become by far
the the that has been a
ridiculously profitable decision but i
remember having a zoom call with two
internet friends of mine who also run
courses and saying to them
you know i don't really feel like i can
do a course teaching people how to be
youtubers like i've only got 1.2 million
subscribers and they were just like
uh yeah are you hearing yourself right
now i was like i mean i've only got 150
million subscribers like why why would
anyone sign up to youtube course for me
like what the hell do i know like to
talk to the guys got 20 million
subscribers
and they were like you have no idea what
you just said yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly
it happens everywhere that happens to
the best of us i think you know we
downplay our own
uh achievements um and it's like if you
don't
if you don't take a moment to actually
reflect on what you've achieved
then
you'll never really be happy you're
always chasing that next thing i
actually wrote in the acknowledgments of
my third book
i wrote something that might be
perceived as narcissistic but it's
really trying to kick myself into
the gear of like taking pause looking
back at what i've achieved up to this
point even though in the day-to-day i
don't really think it's a big thing or
whatever i walk around like oh i'm a
sunday time's best
like i i wrote like take a moment to
enjoy this this present uh
peace just take uh i can't remember
exactly what i said but it was along the
lines of you're doing a good thing keep
going and believe in yourself and that's
it and i think
i have to remind myself of that every
day i actually have an affirmation that
i i read every single day to that effect
because it's very easily lost in this
world where we can constantly comparing
ourselves to someone who has more
followers or you know more achievements
or whatever the accolades that we
compare ourselves by and it's become
more prevalent i guess in this social
media driven world do you find that
affirmation helps
yeah massively um the affirmation is
kind of based on
a thread that i read from melanie
perkins the founder of canberra um so
canva is amazing uh she's australian
yeah she's australian yeah yeah um their
offices are in sydney
and
her founder story is amazing she did it
on how i built this oh and she's oh
that's a good episode
really good episode for anyone that's
like
thinking about funding and the barriers
that you need to get through man she
hustled for three years trying to get
funding and now you know obviously you
know she's bringing the power of design
to billions of people worldwide but she
wrote this thread um on linkedin
and the thread was basically her entire
journey step by step of everything i
read the whole thing and one of the
elements was uh oh they got one of their
rejections
and she wrote a note to herself which
was
melanie you're doing a really hard thing
you'll get through it and you will build
a massively wealthy productive company
that you've always dreamed of yada yada
and i've basically written myself a
version of that to keep myself in the
straight and narrow you know reminding
myself of you're doing a hard thing
but you're going to get through it and
it's about 95 persistence
and consistency is key to getting
through anything and so you're going to
have up and down days but if you just
remind yourself of the affirmation it's
been it's been good for me thus far i've
only been doing it for about um a year
or so that's quite a long time yeah yeah
we have to try affirmations about two
days
so here i'm thinking yeah i do gratitude
i've done gratitude for a long time
that's been pretty game changing for me
i just shared it on instagram for
700 days every day
i would i've been doing for a lot longer
than that but i thought to inspire my
audience i would do 15 days of three
things i'm grateful for every single day
and it could be something like you know
i got a beautiful coffee or someone
smiled at me in the park or the other
and then i went from 15 to 30 to 60 to
700 plus days yeah yeah every single day
yeah um
one thing that strikes me is that like
so
from the outside like you seem to kind
of have it all in that
you know you got three three cookbooks
sunday times bestseller like
ridiculously cool instagram page youtube
channel you're doing this cool stuff
you've got the background as a gp you've
got the credentials to prove it you've
got more books on the way i'm sure
you've got this new app that you've just
launched like
why do you need an affirmation saying
bro it's gonna be okay you're doing a
hard thing i i think
it's uh it's a good question i think
it's easy to look at the veneer of what
we put out on social media
and
not really let people into how much of a
[ __ ] show the backside is you know
because if people saw what my morning
was like you know it's just like
constant pandemonium
starting a tech company was is probably
one of the hardest things i've ever done
because
it's bootstrapped we're not funded and
creating a
scalable product that is well designed
and works functions well and all that
kind of stuff requires a lot of effort
and a lot of quality assurance and all
that kind of stuff and i'm basically
doing all that kind of stuff at the
moment and i'm i'm learning to love it
and i've got that mindset but man it is
every day there is a problem every day
there is something that i'm trying to
figure out every day i'm having pangs of
anxiety about whether this is a good
investment of well over 100k
you know all these different
things are constantly chipping away
at my confidence level so what you might
see on the outside as
a guy with all the qualifications and
books and and all this thing going well
for him uh is actually
just a a sort of hologram or like a a
a mirage
of actually what the reality is um
you know
i think there's different ways of
describing to myself what and what my
day's like like the very vernacular that
we use about how we describe our day
like oh i'm busy or you know it's a
pandemonium like i've just said behind
the um
behind the scenes i think
basically leads to what the reality
becomes in your mind at least and so
i have to get into the habit of actually
telling myself it's okay it's okay and
that's where the affirmations come in
that resonates so much like i have found
myself using that kind of
terminology like
for any anytime i find myself thinking
of using the word busy i have like a
allergic reaction yeah
i i don't do that but still like and so
i don't say it externally but still
internally i you know sometimes get to
the end of there and be like damn that
was a pretty mental day but it was
pretty cool and then i was like hang on
like why like the reason i left medicine
was to not to have like a fairly stress
free free life where i don't have to
worry about life and death decisions and
yet sometimes it feels as if within the
team within the business like oh my god
we have to get this video out otherwise
like the world's going to end up yeah
yeah we can just relax take a step back
chill the [ __ ] out it's all good yeah i
have to remind myself of that and when i
and then when i realized okay i need to
remind myself of that i really need to
remind the team of that but yeah they're
just going to be going off of my energy
which if by default it's like you know
let's go let's go let's go yeah you know
everyone is going to sort of fall into
that you know fall into step with that
yeah and it takes a little bit of like
take a step back this is actually pretty
cool it's pretty freaking weird that you
can have a business that just makes
videos makes silly internet videos and
you know does reasonably well like let's
let's enjoy this yeah yeah that's an
interesting i'd love to get your
perspective on that actually because as
someone with a large team or a larger
team than me anyway
uh how your energy is perceived by
others is probably going to have a
ramifications on you know how everyone's
feeling in the culture as well within
that and i i have to remind myself of
that as well because even when i speak
to
karen who runs my life she's always
whenever we have a call she's like she
always asks me this thing i've already
just realized it now how are you doing
like are you feeling okay how is your
it's always with the expectation that
i'm super stressed and i'm really busy
and like she's there she's very motherly
she like calms you down she's like like
an anti-anxiety pill for me every time i
talk to her afterwards i just feel so
much lighter but i think i have to
remind myself of that because i'm
probably having a
uh a slightly negative impact on the way
she perceives everything going on as
well whereas in reality you're right
we're you know messing around with
fruits and vegetables talking about the
health benefits and putting out some
colorful content yeah
that's pretty good yeah i remember
yesterday you know we were having
discussion with one of the team members
about you know we're launching a new
cohort of our youtuber academy and there
was one specific like type of event we
were running that i was a bit like why
are we doing this it seems like a bad
idea and i think just sort of my energy
was
it was it was it was definitely just
basically being a massive dick about it
and just be like what the hell is going
on here kind of vibes yeah and then it
took another team member in the room to
be like hey it's all right you can we
can have the conversation but it doesn't
have to be like this where it's just
like my my default way of i think
communicating is very just like kind of
straight in yeah and that's just really
bad and i was thinking about it
afterwards they're like wow that was
just really bad yeah
why was i why why was i talking like
that it's not the end of the world yeah
we've still got a whole month to go and
even if we didn't like what the hell
we're doing bringing zoom course
teaching people how to be youtubers like
this is this is not life and death i
don't need to be a dick about it yeah
and it's just i think
it's that that that
reminder sometimes it needs a reminder
from someone else that hey the way that
you're acting is having this impact on
other people stop that yeah yeah because
otherwise it's just like it's so easy
just be in our own heads and not realize
the impact we're having on others i
think yeah absolutely i think so and
i think like our frenetic behavior can
definitely impact culture a wider scale
in an organization um but it's good that
you've got like some insight into that
because a lot of people don't get to
that until like years and years later
when they realized oh i've been addicted
to everyone for like five years and
that's why no one sends me a christmas
card yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i need to need to be reminded of
that more often
because it sort of feels like we're
following the chronology but then we're
going over there
right now
you're on the flight to japan
and you've posted your first thing where
you're like i am a doctor and here is a
recipe for how to be healthier and
you're really like oh my god all my
medic friends are going to cringe at
this yeah uh and then you land in japan
what happens next uh so i immediately
meet up with some of my friends um it
was like
i was basically there because i made the
last minute decision to just get the
hell out of sydney whilst i just need to
be out my head whilst i press play and
everything and the reaction was amazing
i got uh like
so many text messages
uh from friends and even a parody video
of my introduction to the intro to the
youtube i think already within like like
12 or 14 hours they'd already made a
parody video some of my friends and it
was
if you've seen like one of the first
videos ever put it's the doctor's
kitchen on a on a blackboard and then i
add fruits and vegetables to it and
stuff so they did the same thing with a
piece of paper the doctor's kitchen and
putting like wine and like you know all
these like burgers and all this kind of
stuff around it and then doing the theme
tune
but they're literally doing it miming it
like that instead of actual like the
ukulele music um so so yeah it was a
really good reaction and it was
again speaking to some of my senior
consultants when i got back
saying i saw your video and i was like
and i was like i really loved it i think
it's great i think what you're doing is
awesome should definitely continue all
that kind of stuff and it was that sort
of early support that allowed me to
really push on and carry on and like you
know i don't think i've ever had any
viral moments or anything but
just the consistency of like getting
good feedback from people and growing on
this medium and you know that that
instantaneous feedback i think was was
really pivotal on me continuing to do
what i wanted to do and i never thought
about leaving medicine at that point
or you know moving on from medicine i
mean i really really
done that over the last month or so but
i never saw it as like a book or you
know media career or anything like that
that was never really the intention it
only really was inserted after things
kind of came at me and i was reacting to
them rather than being proactive about
it i'm learning to be a bit more
proactive now because i've sort of been
dragged along this journey
and and only over the last year or so am
i really trying to take it by you know
what's that analogy
yeah by the horns yeah yeah i don't know
if you've had that as well like
when you started doing videos i i guess
things would have like pulled you along
in terms of like brand deals or
collaborations and all that kind of
stuff but now it seems like you're being
quite intentional about what you want to
do in terms of yeah
i think because i had run a business
previously and i made loads of mistakes
running that and read other books about
it being like i would really wish i'd
read this five years ago but it wouldn't
have applied to me five years ago
because
like you know a book called uh the
e-myth revisited i don't know if you
come across that ah it will it will
change your life really hundred percent
it will change your life it changed my
life in 2019 when i read it being like
oh my god it's basically about
delegation and why it's so hard yeah it
just like sounds like a simple thing and
i know that when i started sex med the
courses company uh i wouldn't i was not
ready to receive that message because i
was in the mind of i'll do everything
myself i'd do a better job than anyone
else of doing the thing that yeah
because abcde
and then six years later i was like damn
i really wish i delegated more oh my god
that sounds yeah like i need something
have you got a business coach
i
uh do in and out actually yeah so uh
she's had a bit of a break um but i had
one at the start of last year um monthly
for about six or seven months nice
really pivotal yeah really it was just
like milestone driven you know like we
only checked in once a month
everything was yeah that that was really
good that was kind of what led me to
building the app and actually sticking
to a schedule because of her yeah yeah
having a coach's game changing yeah i
discovered the whole coaching thing in
like 2020 and so i had a bunch of
different coaches like weekly um so if
you're in the market for another one i
can recommend you to a guy you know
who's also left medicine yeah really he
comes from that you know he was
cambridge medic a few years ago who now
does business coaching stuff yes and
really helps out with
please do yeah i'll do i'll do an intro
afterwards but yeah it was um
yeah so i think when i was approaching
the youtube channel stuff i already had
that experience of
well failing but like you know failing
failing upwards and building a business
and sort of making sure that i went
along yeah with the courses company to
the point that when the youtube channel
started to do well and i started to
think in terms of it being a business
yeah
i still had loads to learn like reading
the e-myth reading books like traction
like half the books here are business
books that i just sort of books about
leadership and management and things
like that where it felt like
every time i was reading a new book i
was like oh my god like it's it's as if
this person has been inside my soul that
knows what problems i'm currently having
yeah i'm like this is not surprising
because like businesses have been
solving these problems for like 200
years yeah there is like literature on
this and like i'm a freaking medic like
i should know that there is literature
and guidelines about all of the things
i'm struggling with yeah it's like we
hired 15 people before i first before i
read a book about hiring and i was like
damn i wish i'd read that on day one oh
because like yeah why why why am i
making [ __ ] up like
there is bmj best practice there is up
to date like this is a thing yeah yeah
absolutely and i was discovering that
world of
i definitely need to read that book
because i i'm in that position right now
where i feel like i can't delicate
because i know this but i know how to do
the customer service i i really want to
you know instill like confidence in them
and all that kind of stuff you know yeah
that that sounds pivotal because i think
that's gonna be a massive blocker to
scaling yeah um if you can't delegate
appropriately um yeah learning that the
hard way so i'm definitely going to take
you off on that so do you so you started
posting uh sort of videos on instagram
and youtube under this
doctor's kitchen thing yeah and it
sounds like you sort of thought about
the branding and music and stuff in the
early days yeah
what happened next uh so i uh
was working alongside doing all that
kind of stuff so it was like you know ad
hoc posting all that kind of stuff i did
like a few restaurant reviews and all
that and yeah you know just enjoy mostly
on instagram or all in instagram pretty
much yeah mostly the youtube stuff was
like tutorials and a few recipe videos
and stuff but i found even early on even
today the
the need to constantly
video and then edit and then put it out
i was never able to hit a consistent
posting schedule even today
the only things i consistently post or
now are things like facebook instagram
uh a bit of twitter but my podcast as
well it's probably the the most rigorous
in terms of
ever putting something out every single
it's mostly like instagram like how how
much effort were you putting into these
instagram like uh posting videos and
things probably putting in quite a bit
of effort because i would make a new
recipe every time i would like write it
down i would also add it to the website
okay like there was a big collection of
like janky looking videos on on the old
website that have now been taken down
we've got them professionally shot yeah
as we have for the app and stuff but
yeah it was a lot of that in the early
days it was pretty analog
so like so you'd you'd be working in
emerson department then in the evenings
and weekends you'd be hustling to get
these recipes out and get these videos
done yeah and the good thing about
working in australia is that they have
different working arrangements than they
do in the uk right so
i was working like four days on four
days off which sounds like the dream for
a lot of people over here in the uk and
anytime you did over time they actually
pay you overtime as well it's just like
the thing it's just very normal over
there um
and that gave me a lot of time to
actually put into the instagram stuff
and so if i didn't have that opportunity
and i didn't have that time i probably
wouldn't have been able to consistently
post and build up that audience and
interrupt the community and all that
kind of stuff and i think also there is
some like as you might have found as
well
there is some
value in being the doc who also does the
doc stuff and then does recipes as well
that's always been like you know the
intrinsic proposition yeah um so yeah
that would that was really useful in the
early days okay and so like normally in
the early days of stuff
there's you know it's you're putting a
lot of stuff out there and you're not
getting like immediate traction
um what was that experience like for you
like putting all this effort into stuff
like
was it was it like going viral
immediately or like
what what the numbers looking like it's
really slow so like i think i only uh
hit a thousand subscribers like three or
four months in um
like four months on instagram yeah yeah
for not even getting to a thousand
points no no definitely not no no it
wasn't immediate at all and then like
you know like 2003. we're talking like
daily posting or weekly posting i was
posting probably once every two or three
days it was pretty ad hoc um and to be
fair like even now it's not as
consistent as it should be like yeah i'm
really bad at social media um and
yeah like
i remember having the because i so i was
in um
sydney until march 2016
and then when i got back i almost
immediately got approached by a literary
agent
and right off the back of a few
thousands of the back of literally three
or four thousand that was it yeah that
was it at that time and when i got my
book deal i think i was literally on
five or six thousand it wasn't a big
influence yeah no way so they saw
something beyond
the
the number of followers they saw
the
the value they saw the you know the
proposition of a doctor who knows what
he's talking about talking about
nutrition has got an interesting
personal story they saw all those
different bits
the the brand was like also i guess
attractive to them but now actually in
future books we're moving a bit away
from the brand and moving more towards
dr rupi as a sort of cooking personality
um
rather than and that's like an
intentional decision because
um as we might talk about later with
cookbooks most people buy into personal
brands when it comes to cooking
and nigella and stuff exactly rather
than a brand brand yeah exactly so
you'll notice that jamie moved away from
the naked chef which is how he actually
started he was known as the naked chef
now he's jamie oliver and the same thing
could be said of a few other people
yotam has always been like yo terminator
language that's always been the brand
but that's very much personally him
um so yeah that's that's sort of the
direction that we're going in as well
with dr rubio i'm still going to keep
doctor's kitchen for the other stuff as
well so i think that's like
it means that i can
express what the doctor's kitchen stands
for with different ambassadors and
personalities across different
geographical locations so i'm not
inherently tied to it that's good the
way i look i look at it is what i'm
trying to create is like what andy
predikem has done for headspace andy
prudikum is the founder of headspace and
the guy who started in the guy who
narrates all of it but people know
headspace more than their yeah i've
never heard of him and i've been excited
yeah yeah um and that's kind of what i
want to do with the doctor's kitchen
yeah the people in the uk and parts of
australia in america might know dr rupee
yeah but i want them to know doctor's
kitchen a bit more interesting yeah i
think yeah this is something that i i've
heard from a lot of creators i think
there is this
there's this sort of like progression
in terms of autonomy so when you're
working as a doctor you have basically
no autonomy
you're kind of being told what to do
especially especially as a junior and so
then the next step is to kind of do your
own thing under your own brand so
someone like me yeah where it's like oh
now i have the autonomy to do kind of do
what i want but then you realize
when you're at this stage where you can
do what you want the problem is that
it's so tied to my personal brand and
that actually removes autonomy because
now i can't
just well i could but like i i i feel
like i can't just like fly to i don't
know where wherever and just hang out
with friends
because we have a video with deadline
and it's my personal channel it needs to
have stuff yeah so then the next level
of autonomy up is building a brand
like the part-time brand yeah that does
not have my name in it yeah where my
name pushes it initially but it's not so
intrinsically tied to it that it becomes
impossible to sort of separate the two
things out yeah yeah it sounds like you
kind of started out with the brand yeah
and now you're branching out into the
personal thing but still benefiting from
the benefit of the brand i.e the
autonomy and the fact that you don't
have to be front and center all the time
exactly yeah because what i've realized
is that it is as great as it is and as
amazing it is to have this feedback and
like interaction with with people and
it it can detract from the grand
division of what i'm trying to do which
is scale up you know healthy eating for
millions of people around the world you
know i can't be a singular person doing
that it has to be under an umbrella i'm
happy doing all the other stuff like you
know with cookbooks and stuff because
that's not necessarily me having to post
every single week and and you know the
podcast i do really out of like the love
of doing the podcast so i really enjoy
that but i don't want to be tied to it
where it becomes something that you you
have to work toward and you're doing it
because you have to rather than you want
to if you see what i mean i know you
mean it's an interesting conundrum that
creators are and i think that have come
from a personal brand um and branching
out going forward isn't it yeah
definitely so
so he had six thousand followers on
instagram at the time
you got a literary agent approaching you
for a book deal yeah what was that like
that was really surreal when i got back
into the uk uh it was like literally i
started working as a salary doctor so
you know regular gp surgery doing a bit
of out of hours on the side as well
doing a few courses and all that kind of
stuff so still keeping the medical side
of things going um
and then a literary agent coming out of
nowhere who
you know was referred to me probably
because someone who is a big fitness
influencer referred uh them to me and
said oh i followed this guy he puts out
really good content you should check it
out they checked it out they saw this is
pretty cool and you know i see the
trajectory of where this is going and
that's where we had the initial
conversation it was just over coffee and
i was kind of like blown away because i
was i was literally going to a late
shift that day yeah and i just have a
coffee and it was like so house or
somewhere i was like this is fancy and
you know this is a different world to
what i'm used to and also it's kind of
you know i've only been doing it for
like six or seven months at the time
what why would they you know five
thousand followers or whatever i was on
it was it was very yeah it was it was
surreal that time and then you know the
conversations with with different
publishers and what happened was um
uh something called a preempt so the
publisher basically preempted it going
to
auction where you know there's a
proposal that's delivered and then like
whatever so the proposal actually went
to them initially
and they bid on it and um yeah the rest
is history really which publisher was
there harpercollins it was thornson's
imprint um and it was
her name was carolyn she's since moved
from harper but she was like really
forward thinking she really saw it and
it was it was so strange because i went
to the news uk building
one of the 15th or 16th floor all glass
buildings looking out into the shard
there's little on me walking in and on
the big tv screen they've got images of
me and my youtube channel and like my
instagram and some of the recipes and
all that kind of stuff and it was
they were trying to sell them to me yeah
themselves to me and i was like this
should be the way around you know this
is so weird like why are you trying big
office you know harpercollins whatever
um
that that yeah that was very strange um
but they really saw they really painted
out this vision of what the brand should
be and what they could do with the
recipes and the type of people that
wanted involved and that kind of stuff
they really had a vision for it and so
when i would talk about like i was
dragged in this
this direction i wasn't drag kicking the
stream obviously i was loving the
journey but i i i never really had
thought about what the next milestones
are after book one book two et cetera
it's only until recently that i've
actually figured that out
that's been like a really cool
experience it was a very cool experience
very surreal and at the same time i
don't know if you've had experience with
your mom but my parents are like uh yeah
okay this is cool but like you know
stick to medicine yeah yeah yeah
even today like you know my dad's always
asking
about
how how work works and stuff i mean
they know i'm on a sabbatical now
but like you know like oh when you're
going when are you going back to the
hospital i i'm not i'm not going back
straight away i'm taking some time i
want to focus on these things first you
know it's it it is kind of jarring every
time i get that yeah i mean i've been
having those conversations multiple
times a week for the last like four
years so
you're in good company here yeah yeah
exactly i i think it's an asian thing as
well you know the status that's
that's inherent in being a doctor in the
community it's very hard to
be yeah i sometimes think about that
like i i think i wonder if it's less
about the status and like my my my
theory on this is like
you know with my mom for example she
doesn't actually care about status and
i'm sure your parents don't
directly either but it's like
in in their generation medicine and
solid job is the path to the good life
yeah
where actually and for even
people working in tech right now like
it's such a different thing than it was
in our parents generation yeah and so
you know working at ibm and working away
for 40 years and getting the company car
in the health insurance and stuff was
the path to the good life that is not
the part of the good life anymore yeah
and so i think
our parents are probably still in that
mindset where solid job is actually the
thing to optimize for because they have
our own best interests at heart yeah
absolutely and i think
yeah you're right i think it's like um
they wouldn't label it as status yeah
but it's
definitely connected to happiness i
guess you know because you got
stability and yeah you know consistency
and
you're doing ultimately a good thing you
know but not many vocations can really
say that about their day-to-day um do
you so do you get the sense that
from your from from your parents or from
other people that
you have left behind at the noble thing
of saving lives to be just another one
of those influences that writes
cookbooks ugh kind of vibes
in in a in a small way i think probably
not as harsh as that
but but yeah i think there is um an
element of that
however
i thought i've obviously done a lot of
thinking around this in terms of
what is the amount of
effective altruism i guess you could
call it that you can conjure up using
your profession and i think
on a one-to-one basis it's a lot more
literal and it's a lot more
it's tangible in that i'm having a
direct impact on this person by giving
them my time
prescribing giving them a plan etc etc
whereas when you're doing something
across a screen you don't really
understand what the tangible impacts are
uh and and how do you measure that
impact one of the reasons why i'm
starting in the tech world because i i
want to be able to actually measure the
impact that we're having
tangibly on people's health using
different metrics eventually
um and unless you get those lovely
emails and texts and voice notes from
from fans like
your recipes have really helped me out
this is my story and i've had i'm
blessed to have had many of those you
don't really get that one-on-one
connection you don't get that like thank
you card you know um
so i think that that's definitely one of
the elements of it but i
my family my parents are pretty
understanding about the magnitude of the
impact and the reason why is because
some of the friends have started
benefiting from my content
and they're calling them it's like yeah
i don't repeat stuff and like you know
my sugar levels are improved and like
you know my cholesterol is that and i've
lost weight and like all of her friends
are losing weight you know the there are
tangible impacts that they're seeing
like he hasn't met them and isn't that
amazing the fact that you can have
an impact on people that you've never
even met weird
yeah if so if if someone had told you
kind of when you were doing gp training
for example this was going to be how it
would end up yeah
definitely not i would have thought i
would have left medicine along
before i did any of this kind of stuff
actually i
when i was doing management uh i had a
buddy of mine who actually left straight
after doing f2 and worked for a bunch of
biotech companies san fran now moved to
new york and he's loving life
um and so i was
amongst a community of people that were
already thinking about what life was
like after medicine
um
but yeah no i wouldn't have thought i
would have been doing this when i was gp
training no way there's definitely not
that wasn't that it wasn't the intention
to you know to tv and programs and all
that kind of jazz so what's
when you when you're getting kind of
approached by a publisher like this to
do to do a cookbook yeah what does that
what does that look like like what what
dream are they selling you yeah so
they're they're selling uh so it's a one
book deal my initial book deal um
they're selling
uh positioning
when they're gonna be launching what the
competitor titles are what their
aspirations are for the brand going
forward how they're investing in you uh
in more than just one book even though
they're only giving you one book deal
because they want to de-risk it to
themselves
but also the resources that they're
throwing at you as well so
photography prop stylists
copy editing
testing all this different stuff there's
a whole army of people that never get
really seen
in the cookbook making process
that costs a lot of money as well so
it's it's no wonder people don't do
more self-published
professional cookbooks anyway um loads
of ebooks and that kind of stuff yeah
but yeah like
why it costs a lot so like to my mind it
seems that recipe decent photos long
eighty-five millimeter zoom lens f4
sorted yeah yeah there's more to it than
that there's a lot yeah so i mean even
like right where we're sitting right now
you know we're surrounded by
certain lights and cables and cameras
and all that kind of stuff we have
on a cookbook shoot you have not just a
food stylist but you have a prop stylist
as well food stylist you have a food
stylist and a prop stylist and a sous
chef okay and a uh camera person and
then their hand as well you have all
different types of um angles that you
shoot from okay there's like a story to
be told and there are very subtle things
that i only learnt about when i actually
went to the food shoot about how the
whole book has a particular aesthetic
and you know i used to think this is
just like you said like top down you
know that's about it but you know in the
first couple of books there were
little edges like little stylist
elements that tell a story the whole
thing on the on the book that you're
looking through at the moment i was very
much uh
trying to give the impression of
simplicity yeah so that's why most so
nice
yeah most of the recipes i want to top
down
and show you the indulgent aspects of
eating and also like you know um
they they minimize the clutter so if you
look at the the first couple of books
there's loads of like soda water on the
side and there's like scattering of
parsley everywhere i've got like you
know folded napkins i was like no i want
i want to get rid of all that and i want
to tell this kind of story so yeah that
the persian style brown lentils is sort
of
that's the the way i wanted the whole
book to appear so yeah pointing at the
camera
and
it's like this is so good yeah and like
it's weird because um even
that that's a a paper back yeah right in
the hardbacks that i mentioned so hard
books are more expensive and then they
also have an image per recipe this has
got 80 images i believe whereas the
hardbacks will have like hopefully an
image per recipe and that's like the
dream but that costs a lot because
you've got to get printing costs you're
going to get paper costs you've got to
get all these different things so
everything kind of
everything is like compounded into
one
everything that goes into making that
book
is super expensive
okay so for example i'm just curious
here so you've got this image yeah which
is like the super sick looking sorry for
people on the audio you should watch
this on youtube
you'll see the
is this like a real dish that you cooked
or is it like a fake food or no no one
else cook it or like yeah no so so when
you see like uh uh
an image of like an m s chocolate cake
or a mcdonald's
a lot of that is staged a lot of that is
fake everything that we've shot in all
the books is always real it's cooked
there i oversee everything like you cook
it yourself
no no no i don't cook anything yeah yeah
there's like professional cooks cooking
because they have to be like an assembly
line because we're doing like sometimes
eight nine recipes in a day okay and you
know they're like professional chefs and
they're following your recipes they're
following my recipes
to the state like my bedroom yeah to the
to the like the the detail they're
following every single recipe
and what what people don't realize is
that i'm so busy like involved in like
how it's being shot and looking at the
the draft image and like maybe getting
my hand in there or something like that
the food's being cooked at the same time
okay so this is literally like an
assembly and it happens over the course
of about a week as well so these things
are like
really yeah and i guess they're also
like testing the recipes to make sure
that the like it's actually one
tablespoon of olive oil rather than 18
or whatever yeah so usually ideally what
should happen is you create the recipes
and then i work with a recipe tester who
then tests all the recipes and then they
go back to me and i review the changes
and make sure you know they're in line
with my nutrition principles and all the
rest of it what we've done on the next
book actually which i haven't talked
about yet is we actually uh crowdsourced
uh loads of recipe testers from my
newsletter list so i went to
i looked at on mailchimp you you can
look at your like most engaged
subscribers so i looked at my most
engaged subscribers and there were about
10 000 people who opened it like you
know more than four or five times in the
last like three months let's say so
engage subscriber and so i sent an email
out to them saying look i need some
foodie testers here's a google form if
you're interested then fill out this
form and then we'll send you a single
recipe for you to test in your own time
you fill out a questionnaire you take
images of it we might use the images in
the back of the book to you know make a
nice collage and stuff
and your name as well if you want to be
in the acknowledgements and we got
something like 1500 responses to that
nice yeah and then we ended up sending
so
so we also had to take their dietaries
as well so you can imagine this is an
organizational nightmare so we got all
the dietaries we had to match all the
100 recipes that i'd created and and
also gone through the test and then give
each recipe to specific people based on
their dietary needs and likes and
dislikes and then they feel like that
and then i read
over 900 responses in a big excel form
of all the pain points all the issues
that they might have had all their
feedback rating would they make this
recipe again
all these questions and that's going to
go into the next book
so each recipe has been tested in a real
actual kitchen
10 times
and from all over the world dude we had
people from like nepal australia rural
france canada america like everywhere
like people because obviously the
is like you know they get it everywhere
so yeah it was it was insane it's yeah
it's a it's amazing
what uh so
i'm i'm not sure if you're allowed to
share your own numbers but like what
what are the economics generally of
cookbook publishing yeah what sort of
ballpark advances do people get like how
much they sell for what are the
royalties like i'm very curious to
understand what this process is yeah
yeah so i give an example of my first
book and um
i don't usually talk about this stuff so
i'm i'm happy to talk handily about it
so
the ballpark for advances for cookbooks
range anywhere between
20 grand to
over 200 250 grand wow um it can be huge
for my first book i i got a really good
offer it was 75 grand considering
not much social media following really
good yeah not much social media
following no traction and book books
nothing like that and was that like
international or just uk or what was
that it was uh uh worldwide okay yeah so
worldwide rights so for people listening
you know uh that you can separate the
markets into uk and australasia and uh
america and europe and all that kind of
stuff so there's worldwide rights uh and
then also you can um separate it further
out into like tv rights as well so
whether they have tv rights as well so
let's say that someone picked up the
doctor's kitchen and then turned it into
a tv show that was tied to the book very
much like what jamie oliver does or
nigella you know are those going to be
separate do you have a royalty bonus
when you get a tv show
and that that bonus i i'm not actually
too sure it could be probably in the
tens of thousands if not more and then
um there's a royalty share as well and
so that can be like 10
but that depends on a threshold and that
threshold can be up and down my
threshold was super high it was like 80
000 copies and so mine hasn't started
paying until like
from the first book until like two years
ago because we've since sold over a
hundred thousand copies of book one but
you know obviously the 80 000 threshold
was super high so they're like
de-risking it to themselves because
creating a book like that costs like a
ton of money um wow so yeah that's
that's the basic economics of of
a cookbook so
so the uh so the idea is that um
you know so you so you would get the
advance and then you earn out the
advanced through royalty payments and
then at some point you start getting
royalty checks once you've earned out
your advance exactly and it sounds like
you've now earned out your advance yeah
so you get quarterly royalty checks yeah
i'll get quarterly royalty tracks from
harper okay and uh yeah yeah the funny
thing is uh i've since become vit
registered and i want to go into the
business and that's the whole thing but
yeah that's basically how it works nice
and so is it a sustainable full-time
living to be a cookbook author
yeah a very important question um it
depends on what your standard of living
is
okay so i think if you're the kind of
person that can
churn out and has the opportunity to
churn out a cookbook a year
and
can yeah it's a lot a lot of work and
can demonstrate sales of a cookbook a
year
then yes i think it could be if you're
happy with
something around
60k a year let's say wow yeah that's
tiny compared to what yeah so you're
saying every year yeah make make a
cookbook from scratch and demonstrate
the ability to sell it yeah are we
talking like hundreds of copy thousands
of copies tens of thousands like oh what
kind i would say like a good uh a good
performing cookbook would be 30 to 40
000 copies yeah i would say that oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's a lot a lot and so it's
it's no wonder you see the same chefs in
the sort of top sellers list right you
have uh great chefs jamie nigella nadia
hussein rick stein
these are really tried and tested chefs
that people love and adore and so
breaking into that market is very hard
so if you look at what joe rix has done
or uh who are the slimming the two
people who's slimming
pinch of gnome they've done phenomenally
well they sell hundreds of thousands not
millions of books you've got rook money
uh arya who sold the roasting team
another really good oh you would love
that that's a great book yeah it's sick
yeah a friend gave it to me as a gift he
was like
rugby's books are fantastic she sold
over a million copies across her series
of books and they're with good reason
they're amazing she was actually on my
bbc show as well
um
yeah if you can get there's only a few
people who actually go into that level
of of you know scale yeah most people do
a cookbook and then they'll never do
another one because they either you know
didn't sell as much or you know it just
just didn't work out for them so
is is just the publishing business
enough to be a full-time living no no
you need to do side hustle things oh
yeah all the so i think like having a
cookbook is
a really nice business card because it
allows you to do other things like you
know you get to do a bit of tv shows you
do some of the live cooking events uh it
has opened the doors for me doing like
collaborations with catering companies
where i design a lot of the menus for
buildings across the uk so i i've got a
collaboration with a company called
gathering gather and they do all the
professional catering for over 200
buildings um in the uk including like
sky lloyd's tsb vodafone so they've got
big big kitchens
and they have my recipes like every
single week that i've designed quarterly
for them
that are like you know nutritionally
balanced and have the story and all the
rest of it and i'll do some like
corporate speaking events for them as
well so i think it's a really good
business card to get your foot in the
door and it demonstrates a bit of
authority um but if you can demonstrate
like sales of like more than 40 50 60
000
that gets you a lot more um i i believe
okay so i guess like yeah this is
similar to like i've spoken to a bunch
of other like non-fiction authors like
generally uh non-fiction self-help slash
business authors who are like
yeah it's really hard to survive just
off the back of royalties on and
advances from books unless you are a
james clear or mark manson who sold
million copies plus and at that point
you're in the sort of upper echelons
exactly but i'm kind of kind of until
that point you still need to hustle and
do courses and speaking and this that
and the other totally sounds like it's
similar in the in the food genre yeah
yeah absolutely and people like again
have this idea of like oh he's got a
cookbook and he's sunday times
bestseller and like he gets to go on tv
and stuff and they equate that with with
wealth yeah like in my head you're
making millions without doing anything
because it's all passive income from the
book sales no but presumably
i'm a little bit off with that no no
you're off with that massively off but i
think what it's allowed me to do is
build a foundation a trustworthy
foundation to
jump off into loads of other activities
that i actually i really want to do like
i love doing books don't get me wrong i
love the feel of cookbooks myself and
the whole process and like that week is
amazing and you know we're about to do
like a a photo shoot with one of jamie
oliver's photographers and stuff so like
the opportunity that cookbooks has given
me is amazing um and i know they're
being used you can like read the amazon
reviews and stuff people love them
but
it's it's not a sustainable income
unless you're willing to you know live
on quite well i wouldn't say it's a
small salary but it's like you know with
everything else that you have to do to
maintain this brand
it it goes very very quickly and i
haven't even talked about agency views
as well because that full advance is cut
by like 20 yeah
yeah oh it's nice industry standard yeah
yeah okay so let's say i wanted to make
a cookbook yeah and i got a deal for
making a cookbook and and then let's say
i'm you know they're like oh ali's
kitchen the cookbook is is on saturday
kitchen yeah whatever the show is called
yeah yeah would they pay me for
appearing on saturday kitchen uh how
does that work so if you're doing a
appearance so i've done appearances like
this morning and a few other so when
you're doing an appearance they don't
pay you for a guest contributor but if
you are being a guest contributor
i mean it's minimal it's like 200 400
pounds something like that to just
appear um and when you think about the
logistics of it you know it's like quite
a few hours every time it's like half a
day
um so
you know all that stuff it
it it doesn't really make ends meet
unless you're going there and you're
promoting your book you know when i when
i did like a this morning
uh promotion i think for the first time
we must have sold like three or four
thousand books in like half a day just
by appearing interesting yeah like in
the in the sort of business self-help
genre
uh terrestrial tv is pointless and it's
all about podcast appearances yeah and i
guess in the cooking genre that's
actually an area in which people do
translate and convert into sales yeah
yeah i guess it depends on the audience
so like what i same thing when i decided
kitchen again it went straight to number
one on amazon because that's a book
buying audience they're super engaged
they see the recipes they immediately go
and buy it
whereas a pot if you're listening to me
on a podcast
unless you're like unless i've described
so beautifully the the the
recipes that you can make from my book
it's not really going to translate into
something whereas if you were to do a
thing about sort of how to how to build
a part-time brand while being a doctor
and stuff yeah and you tell the story of
that on a podcast some people the
podcast list oh hello that's interesting
yeah exactly yeah the number of like
business books that i've bought
immediately on audible or something like
you know after listening to what i pause
that or like i i listen to my first
million quite a bit good i love that
podcast but i've actually had to take a
break from it because it's just too
consistent too many episodes too
consistently i had to have to like i
can't listen to these 100 episodes i
know yeah totally i started listening to
the backlog over christmas because i ran
out but actually uh what i've realized
is because they give so many ideas it's
actually detracting from what i need to
focus on right now which is the business
my side hustle or hustle whatever you
want to call it and so i've actually had
to take a break from my first million
because it's just yeah too much content
but multiple times i've listened to that
and like sam pars like name check robert
green obviously you know 48 pounds a lot
of 50 puzzle or whatever it's called um
and uh a whole bunch of other books i've
lit paused and that clicked i'm like one
click buy yeah i've definitely got that
more audible yeah
i find with podcasts it's almost like
pigs and troughs so like for example in
2019 i was listening to hundreds of
podcasts that year especially while i
was traveling back and forth
an hour each way to work yeah doing f2
and then it was like all of those ideas
from the podcasts uh in a way then there
was a two year period of putting them
into practice yeah and now i'm getting
like literally getting back into the
podcast in the last week so i was i've
been listening to my first million and a
couple of episodes having not
heard a podcast for like a year or two
at this point wow yeah yeah like i i
went completely off podcast as the
business was growing and as i was like
actually business books are the thing i
need in my life right now yeah yeah yeah
whereas now with the podcast i find that
the conversational is really great and
you get a lot of ideas but yeah when
you're in execution mode you need to be
executing and learning about the
specific thing and then is it sort of
like divergence and convergence yeah
like divergence of ideas that you get
from podcasts and then convergence when
you're like right this is my angle i
know i'm making an app i'm going to
listen to all of the audiobooks around
how to build an app and how to scale a
text startup yeah
that's a that's a really good point
that's basically the situation that i'm
in in fact the last audiobook i read i
listened to was inspired and that's
basically all about product teams and
what the structure of that looks like
because as a non-tech founder i need to
know what does an engineer do what does
the designers do how do you create
coherent systems such that you can
actually scale a company and know
who you're hiring as well so yeah taking
a break from podcast has actually been
pretty good for me because i was an avid
podcaster i still sort of am but i will
come back to it at some point yeah why
the app what is the deal with the app
i've just downloaded the app and i'm
going to start following the recipes on
the app but yeah what's this what's the
rationale so the i've wanted to do an
app for years right um so ever since i
two years ago brought in a bunch of
followers
to investigate what the barriers to
healthy eating were for them i had this
idea of creating a
an application or a web-based platform
where i could teach people how to cook
well every single day and keep them on
the straight and narrow and that has
kind of morphed into
a recipe planning app uh that you can
download on your phone and links with
supermarkets so you can actually order
the ingredients with one click yeah you
can't do that right now okay
but that's sort of the product roadmap
okay and i've got a whole bunch of other
ideas as well that i'll chat about very
very briefly but
the the app has been in the back of my
mind the whole time because i really
wanted to create the headspace for
healthy eating and really enable the
brand to span beyond what i can do in
the uk and actually have an impact
going forward and so
yeah the process of building it has been
crazy because
we're not just another recipe app we
enable people to uh filter the recipes
according to health goals and so me and
the research team look through a whole
bunch of research and you can find out
our process for refining all this
research on the website and we look at
the dietary patterns and the ingredients
that align with things like skin health
mental health in terms of nutritional
psychiatry
brain health like a whole bunch of
different health goals
and and even inflammation using the
dietary inflammatory index as well and
then you're allowed to uh filter
according to your dietary preferences as
well as your allergens and intolerances
and dislikes and then you get a library
of all these different ingredients such
that you don't have to think about
what you need to do with the brussels
sprouts that you see in tesco's or
whatever you have loads of ideas with
step-by-step images of everything
so you can cook well every day the
product roadmap is really to create
something like a spotify playlist that
delivers you in delivers you recipes
that actually you want to intuitively
cook based on your preferences and what
you've liked before and then also that
one click ability to get the ingredients
but also i think in the future which is
what i think i described on this podcast
i can't remember is the other one that
we recorded but basically where you have
ghost kitchens
creating the recipes for you and
delivering it such as nutritionally
balanced for you
we also want to have wearables
indicating what you should be eating as
well based on things like
ordering data
exercise data continuous glucose
monitoring data microbiota data as well
so that's all the stuff in the future
but we're starting with a very simple
recipe app which is the doctor's kitchen
app you can get on apple store and it's
just an apple store at the moment
because i'm bootstrapping it and that i
mean that is a whole podcast in itself i
guess in terms of like how you fund
everything because everything that i've
channeled from the books that led to the
podcast that's led to
corporate speaking events all that has
been channeled into creating this app so
i'm basically
putting everything on red
interesting yeah i think definitely not
part two want to explore the the
economics of building an app yeah and
what it's like building out the product
team what it's like outsourcing stuff
it's like working with agencies i think
that's so interesting yeah i think a lot
of people have this dream of like oh i'd
like to build an app someday and i need
like i i get so many medics that come to
me like hey you know i i really want to
build an app and i'm always like oh are
you sure about that yeah yeah and
especially like non-technical founders
oh it's fine i can come up with the idea
i can do the mock-ups i'll just i'll
just hire someone be like yeah how much
does it cost to hire someone is it a lot
of money but what sure surely it's you
know a few thousand dollars i can hire
someone bangladesh like have you ever
tried it's not that it's not easy yeah
there's all this stuff around building
an app that i'm sure you're not familiar
with totally yeah and if you skimp out
on the costs as well like it'll come
back to bite you as well so i i learned
that and then yeah there's a whole
podcast episode i'd love to get your
opinions on that as well actually yeah
as a non-tech founder i'm learning a lot
of things the hard way but i feel like
i'm going along this educational process
where i could perhaps teach other people
as well have you read uh the hard thing
about hard things
no oh amazing audiobook uh that's by ben
horowitz from andreas horowitz yes ben
horowitz yeah yeah which is all about
the
struggles of building a tech company
it's sick definitely something to listen
to so the e-myth revisited will change
your life i think about how things are
quite nice it won't change your life um
are you are you thinking of hiring any
people full-time recently uh in the near
future yeah yeah very much so okay uh
yeah i i have tons of recommendations
okay cool
uh it's gonna be great and i'll
introduce my business coach as well yeah
if that's a good fit definitely man i
feel like this has been like a business
therapy session brilliant yeah well
thank you for coming on my pleasure
we're gonna do a collab where you're
gonna teach me healthy weeknight meals
hundred percent uploaded the app the
episode we'll put links to the books the
apps and thank you for gifting us this
little lovely course doctor's kitchen
three two one um book and yeah it's been
great having you on appreciate it man
yeah my pleasure all right so that's it
for this week's episode of deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
gonna be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye